THEY ARE GOING TO CALL OUT JOE
BIDEN, HE BROKE HIS PROMISE.
WHY WOULD A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
BE WARRANTED HERE?
KK BECAUSE THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
HE HAS DONE TO DONALD TRUMP AND
MIKEY WERE SAYING A SECOND AGO,
IT CAN'T BE THAT WE HAVE TWO
TIERS OF JUSTICE IN THIS COUNTR
PER THERE PMP ONE RULE FOR
REPUBLICANS AND A DIFFERENT ROL
FOR DEMOCRATS.
NEAR GARLANDS OF THE HAVE TO
HAVE A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR FOR
TRUMP WHICH MEANS WE HAVE TO
HAVE ONE FOR BIDEN.
ARGUABLY, WHATEVER ELSE WE KNOW
IS TRUE, WE KNOW HE DIDN'T HAVE
THE.
TO DECLASSIFY THE DOCUMENTS.
TICKET LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
OTHER ISSUES OF THE HOUSE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD.
WE HAVE JIM JORDAN, JUDICIARY,
HE WILL BE LOOKING INTO THE DOJ
AND THE FBI.
JAMES AND ME WILL BE LOOKING
ANTHONY 5G, THE ORIGINS OF COVID
.
THE WITHDRAWAL OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN AND HOW IMPORTANT
ARE THESE INVESTIGATIONS?
>> THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
REAL OVERSIGHT IS THEY WON'T
LIFT A FINGER, SO THEY HAVE TO
GET THE TRUTH.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE IRS, THEY
LIED ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THEY LIED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
AT
IT'S TIME TO
GET THE TRUTH AND TO GIVE IT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PEOPLE GIVE THEM THE TRUTH ENDE
IT IS DARK TO KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE ON A GOVERNMENT
AT THIS LIES.
THAT'S IS WHAT THIS A MINISTER
IS A LEFT SPY.
LET ME TO ENTER AS VIEW OF IT'S
HAPPENED OVER CHRISTMAS.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE MY EYES IT.
HE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR SENAT
REPUBLICANS IT TO PASS ALONG A
CONTINUING RESOLUTION BUT YET
THERE WERE OFTEN HELL-BENT ON
GOING HOME WHEN OMINOUS FELLA
THAT HAD A LOT OF RECKLESS
SPENDING BY ALL ACCOUNTS.
MEANWHILE, THEY KNEW THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE WOULD
HAVE A MAJORITY THAT COULD HAVE
WORKED WITH THE REPUBLICANS IN
THE HOUSE.
THAT THEY COULD HAVE GOT
TOGETHER WITH AND BROUGHT A
BUDGET THAT WAS FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE THAT DID NOT ROB IT
FOR MY KIDS AND GRANDKIDS SOUND
THEIR COLLEGE BECAUSE GOING ON
WITH THIS THAT'S WHY VOTED
AGAINST THAT THEY MAY NOT GET M
HAD A TIME STILL DOESN'T.
THE VOTERS JUST GAVE US A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE.
WHY WOULD WE NOT ALLOW THE HOUS
TO START DOING THEIR WORK.
BUDGET PRIORITIES AND REFLECT
THE COMMONSENSE OF THE MCABEE
BOLT REPUBLICAN PUBLICANS AND
THAT COURSE MAQAMAT SINNOTT
ANALOGY THAT THAT WAS A
SURRENDER.
AND THAT IOWA WAS TO IS
INNOCENCE AT THE TIME.
AS WE COME BACK TO SESSION, WE
HAVE GOT TO GET SOME DOUBTS AND
HOLD THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE N
SURRENDER'S, NO MY CAPITULATION
AT.
IT'S TIME TO GET TOP IT WITH THE
.
I TOTALLY AGREE.
IT NOW YOU HAVE A FELLOW
MISSOURI SENATOR THAT SHOWS
GREAT PROMISE IT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO DO A GREA
JOB.
>> ME TOO.
ABSOLUTELY.
I CAN'T WAIT TO WORK WITH HIM.
HE'S GOING TO BE TREMENDOUS AND
MIKAELE WORK TO DO TO.
THIS ALLOWED ACCOUNTABILITY TO
HAD.
THAT'S A LOT OF FIGHTING WE NEE
TO DEFER THE PEOPLE